i always love my conversations with this
man because there's always something
more important than football
going on in his life to talk about and
that is malcolm jenkins of the new
orleans saints back here on the rich
eisen show how you doing malcolm
rich i'm doing good man how you been i'm
doing fine just uh hanging my head on
every rep
that i can get my hand on right now
that's what we're doing right now
in the world between you right now i
know they are so what is going on in uh
in your world with the saints walk me
through what this week's been like
what's what is going on
with you yeah it's still still a pretty
unique you know offseason obviously last
year we didn't have anything
um and this year you know was a lot
different than you know what i've been
used to
where you know we we kind of came in got
our workouts there's some meetings
um and a lot of it was you know player
driven so we we just did
some seven on sevens for the first time
uh and really that was
you know organized and put on by the
players so everything was kind of
you know low-key just going through the
the you know installs
a little bit of the basics uh but still
getting some quality work in
nobody's getting hurt which is you know
the main thing please um yeah
so it's been been great no doubt what
has it been
like without breeze in the mix for the
first time if you're two ten years now
with the saints
malcolm yeah i think you know i think
everybody's you know
looking to see kind of how the leaders
kind of emerge out of this especially
you know at the quarterback position to
see jameson and take some
really kind of stepping into their own
personalities now kind of not being
behind drew
uh and then obviously just you know
myself cam jordan damario davis guys who
you know been leaders on this team uh
you know kind of molding some of the
other younger guys but
honestly i think i think it's been you
know excitement guys have been back in
the building
you know the camaraderie all the some of
the protocols being
loosened you know uh different than it
was last year where we didn't even get
to hang out you know
as teammates so i think guys would just
be more focused on
you know kind of kind of building that
camaraderie figuring out who's going to
be on the team
um and getting back to work and uh what
has the quarterback
situation been like from your
perspective what you're seeing in terms
of leading and competing and things of
that nature
with taysom hill and uh and jameis
malcolm
yeah i think i think you know you see
two guys who really respect each other
who respect the process and
and want to do what's best for the team
obviously last year you know taysom
filled in
and and had some success you know and
and taking us but james has also
been accomplished in this league um and
so you know it's one of those things
where
they're working together but you also
know it's you know it's a competition
and i think it's to make our team better
um both of them i think are our natural
leaders that have
the ear of the locker room and so you
know right now
it's all you know it's all about the
team but i'm sure as
as we get back to training camp and and
things you know start to
heat up um you know that that
competition will heat up as well
what do you think of what's going on
with aaron rodgers in green bay
i know you sometimes spend some time uh
in an analyst chair every
very once in a blue moon but uh i'd love
to know your perspective from a
veteran's position
certainly since the saints do have the
packers week one there's a ton of time
between now and then obviously
but i wonder what you guys think from
afar watching this play out with a
quarterback certainly that you have
defended against
quite a bit uh in the 21st century
situation in the business of the nfl
has he made any uh news yet i haven't i
haven't paid attention to it much i know
you know he's putting his foot down i
want it out uh has there been any
movement or not
there has been zero movement he did not
show up this week
and jordan loves that he will be a
hundred percent ready should he get the
call week one against you
and the saints oh yeah well well i think
you know players
you're starting to see more of it you
know players have the leverage to
to do you know what's best for them in
their career um and i think he's
obviously you know one of the top
quarterbacks you know top three
quarterbacks if not the
top quarterback in his league um and
if he feels like he you know hasn't been
done right by by the teams
and you know he has every right to do
you know what he wants to do we see the
same thing with deshaun watson
um and i think that that kind of
leverages is
you know as a player i'm happy that guys
are taking it upon themselves and
putting you know using the power that
they have because we've surely seen
teams you know on the other foot do the
same to players
you know cut players mid contract trade
them you know and have that
have at it and uh to see a player
reversing that role
you know i think it's encouraging why do
you think the
it's happening more in the nfl now
because we've seen it in the nba quite a
bit and i've had so many conversations
with nfl players saying hey we see in
the nba
uh it's a player-driven league and
obviously in in the nfl there are some
players that drive
revenue drive wins more than losses
why do you think we're seeing more of
this in the nfl now malcolm yeah i think
we're starting to see that the business
of the nfl is booming right you look at
the new tv deals
you know every year you know we are the
the highest grossing sport in america
um and we wear helmets for a living and
now our individual players are starting
to get
you know more notoriety more um you know
access
and leverage off of the field and with
that comes
more power at the negotiating table and
i think once you
start to see a couple guys push against
the establishment
obviously you know you start to create a
pathway for other guys to see
you know that that they can do it as
well and you know an nba
like i said you have a league that's
player driven because they understand
the value they understand
that they are the product and i think
the the nfl has been
sort of nfl players have kind of been
late to the party on that curve is a
little bit
different dynamics in our league but
you're starting to see that shift as
well
uh in the mindset of today's athlete
malcolm jenkins here on the rich eisen
show
one of the many reasons why i like
having you on malcolm is not only
because we can talk
ball but we talk life and uh other
issues
and you know and i i feel like i could
ask you pretty much anything
and so in that regard earlier you
mentioned how you're enjoying the
camaraderie and getting back in a room
because of
protocols being loosened and part of the
reason why that is taking place is
because of vaccines
that vaccinations have actually turned
helped
knock on wood seemingly turn a bit of a
tide on covet 19 in this country
and we're we're hearing quite a bit of
you know sound bites from
colleagues of yours players in the
league that are resistant or wanting to
learn more can you
walk me through what the players
association mindset is or what
a player's mindset is in regards to the
vaccine right now in the nfl
best you can tell malcolm yeah yeah i
think you know
like any any concerned citizen right
who's concerned about their health and
the help of their family members
you know education is the the key part
to this you know if you don't know
any better or don't know the information
you're going to be skeptical to do it
and when it comes to especially african
americans in this country and when it
comes to
medicine um we don't have the best track
record so
you know it comes with you know being
able to give people as much information
as they can
about what the vaccine is what it does
um
how it works um and and let them make
that decision kind of on their own so
it's not a mandatory thing um but
obviously we've seen
not only just in our league but just in
society in general in our communities
um how effective it has been when you
start to get more and more people
vaccinated
that we're able to get back to a little
bit of a sense of normalcy
um but obviously understanding that the
the virus is still very real
still in in you know and we there's
still some things we don't know
about uh the vaccine but there's also
things we don't know about the long-term
effects
of cover 19. so it just comes with you
know
like i said just more dialogue more
information
um to allow people to get to those
decisions uh on their own and make you
know the decision that's best for them
and their family but
are players who are not vaccinated not
allowed to
um i guess convene in a manner in which
it seems like you and
others are convening where you can be as
you sense
protocols being loosened is there
certainly a difference in the way that
that's happening behind the scenes
right now well some simple things just
like you know wearing masks right if
you're
if you're vaccinated you don't have to
wear masks and like
you know for the first time in a year
you know i'm able to go to and from my
house without a mask on
um that feels great you know but if you
haven't gotten it you still
um gotta you know wear that and i'm sure
as we get closer into the season you
know a lot of those protocols will be
hashed out um and kind of you know
reevaluate it
but i'm sure they're going to be
restrictions you know just like there
will be in society you know inevitably
for people who don't and people who do
um i'm sure our protocols will reflect
the same and i think some of that
convenience
um will probably you know nudge guys to
to get the vaccine as well but
you know what we want to do is
especially from a union standpoint is
make sure
that uh nobody's being forced to get it
it's not a mandatory thing
um but also you have to understand you
know that covert is real and
and if you aren't vaccinated they're
going to be some um protocols that you
still have to abide by
okay and then just one last thing so is
the players association
uh taking part in this education program
that you're mentioning i know that ron
rivera
for the washington football team put
together um
you know a presentation with a vaccine
expert to talk to the players and get
them more
uh up to you know uh over maybe even 50
percent vaccination rate on the
washington football
team is there what what what can you
enlighten me about what the players
association is doing
well i know the players association is
working directly with the league and in
tandem with the league
we're coming up with what those
protocols are to make sure that players
you know
are are safe and educated i think the
teams are really
individual clubs have taken it upon
themselves um
you know to to really educate guys i
know even the staff here
um the entire building was 100
vaccinated before the players even got
here
and so you know the players are we're
kind of the last wave of employees
um that are getting access to it um so
you know it's
it's one of those things where i think
they're trying to lead by example and
it's and i'm sure it's a different club
by club
um but the the pa and the league are
working hand in hand to make sure
uh that they won't agree on what the
protocol should be
um but obviously you know prioritizing
um keeping guys safe
what's going on with your foundation
everything else in your life i'd love to
give you the floor because you've always
got something interesting and
fascinating and important going on
what's going on with you
malcolm yeah you know over the years
we've talked about many
issues you know from the criminal
justice system from
education and all these things and um
you know those things i think we i'm
still continuing to push
a lot of work in especially locally in
philadelphia when it comes to policing
and police oversight
but one of the things i've turned my
mind to is just really that
and and we've seen it over covert uh 19
in the pandemic with people struggling
financially
um in any way you want to have impact is
is through financial freedom
um and so i focus my attention to the
wealth gap that
exists in america right now where the
average white family
has about 10 times the net worth of an
average black family and that that gap
is only going to grow
wider as we go on if we don't do
something so my foundations focus on
financial literacy we partnered with uh
a company called a black home company
called gold setters
and our pledge to start a thousand
savings accounts for kids um that'll
allow them to start to invest so we're
giving them money
um at a very early age and teaching them
about investments and not just the
education but actually giving them some
money
to to start investing on their own um
knowing that even that little bit of
education
um grows their chances of being an
investor by the age of 25
going to college and having success um
when it comes to their finances
how can people take part again help out
in volume yeah they can go
find out more about what we're doing uh
if you go to the malcolm
jenkinsfoundation.org
we'll have you know all the things that
we're doing not only with the financial
literacy but some of our other programs
that we're doing
we just had a scholarship um program
that we have in new orleans we've been
doing for 10 years now or over 10 years
uh where our graduates uh you know we
gave out scholarships
um so all of our stuff is there if you
want to donate please support the work
uh if you want to volunteer or just get
more information
all of that information is at the
malcolm jenkins foundation.org
now the reason why you call it that is
because malcolm jenkinsfoundation.org
was already taken
or or why do you call it
the way that you plus it's isn't it
pronounced the i mean
the malcolm foundation malcolm jenkins
no no no no that's only if you're
you know made sense but if it starts the
sentence it's d
malcolm james foundation just like v or
how
oh no oh see now i'm putting two and two
together dominating
yeah you know a certain school up north
for a long time how's that
would you guys do anything y'all got a
new coach yet
no hey we don't malcolm
okay we don't i know you were like you
know hey there's something going on with
aaron rodgers like i would let you slide
on that one but you know
you you're up to speed enough on what's
going on with michigan you understand
that
or the school up north pardon me so uh
how do you think in in in all
seriousness urban meyer will fare
in the nfl uh after all those years uh
in college and at
the ohio state university how do you
think he's gonna
he's gonna do at this next level malcolm
i mean we'll see i think it's always
been
you know a tough transition for coaches
um mainly
um coaches who um
are used to having a certain level of
control on the collegiate level and now
you're in a a locker room with
you know guys like aaron rodgers who can
who can make their own decisions who've
been in the league for a long time who
know what they're doing know how to get
their bodies ready
um and we've seen some coaches struggle
with that we've seen some you know do
well
i think he's been known to be one of
those controlling high intensity
you know type coaches um and so i'd be
interested to see
what the uh what his adjustment you know
is but
you know well it's a tough league and
it's it you can't hide you're very
highly competitive and
and obviously already kind of making
waves with the
the tebow signing and so
we'll see we'll see where that goes well
i mean to me i i thought you know
that also you tell me if i'm wrong that
that that would also indicate to
everybody in the locker room
in jacksonville that if that if it all
works out for us and you play the in the
manner in which
you know uh i i i'd want you to play for
me
that this this is for life that we're
doing what do you think
signing tebow is a way to indicate to
everyone in the in the locker room
that or you think it's just something
that's totally out of left field and
and was maybe a little bit out of pocket
what do you think well
well i don't it's not like he wouldn't
find every player that he played with in
florida right 10 people want a
heisman for him right so i mean if he's
one of those of you if you're going to
be
you know the next league of vp oh for
sure for everything
but uh i think uh i i don't know how
many guys looked at that moving and
you know and respected it as as guys who
are in this league who've worked their
entire lives to be here
work really really hard to stay here in
a highly competitive uh
space i i don't know if it was met with
that kind of reception
malcolm uh love chatting with you uh
best to your family best to
you and what are you doing anything in
the summer uh before training camp
what are you doing you going anywhere
you're gonna just stay put what is
what's your plan
for the summer i'm getting to get out
with the kids a little bit um you know
how old are they enjoy the summer
my my daughters are seven and three oh
your hands so
there's some somebody invented a half
uh birthday i don't know where
[Laughter]
now i've got two half birthdays uh this
month so oh oh
boy i think a seven and a three year
olds they're the ones who invented half
birthdays
malcolm exactly that's so funny
well have a great father's day then uh
in between and let's chat down the line
appreciate it appreciate it that's
malcolm jenkins go everyone check out
the malcolm jenkinsfoundation.org to be
part of all the great works that he is
part of
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here